e
I could
sometimes
for
[Applause]
still
so look at
yourself
some
no no I know
to
me the real claim
it well no I
saw trying to improve the coherency of
this manuscript by
I gave you the summary for the whole
thing last week or the week before now
I'm going to write a summary for every
chapter and hopefully that'll provide a
structure for the
more either elaborate or vague depending
on your perspective arguments that
follow
so all right so anyways what you have is
a summary of the preface which is very
short and then a summary of
uh the argument that I've making
throughout
that it's reasonable to conceive of the
world in two
ways and uh I just tried to reduce that
argument to its essential
aspects and
then the last two pages
contain a description of the instinctive
response to
novelty
and the manner in which that response
finds it representation in
myology and maybe by next week I'll have
like four more chapter summaries or
something for you any
luck okay
so where
generally we've been discussing the
possibility that the dangers that are
inherent to group
identity which is the tendency of group
identity to adopt a total Aran stance
which is a consequence of its of any
group's propensity to try to maintain
its structure over
time we're we're discussing the
possibility that that inevitable
tendency of the group might be
heightened in its danger by certain
types of individual
Psychopathology and I was trying to make
the
argument it's interesting you know this
week in the Atlantic Monthly there's a
discussion of William James and his his
inquiry into religious phenomenology
which was apparently motivated in large
part by his use of nitrous oxide but
there's also an argument in there that
elaborates upon Shelley Taylor's
findings in social psychology some of
you know this that positive Illusions
according to Taylor Foster mental health
anyways that idea has now spread right
out into the mainstream press and the
guy who wrote the Atlantic Monthly
article is making the point
that the validity of a belief might be
determined by whether or not makes you
happy which is very very very dangerous
perspective anyways back to
this back to this main argument the
reason I brought that up is because of
course that's a point that's absolutely
contrary to the point that I've been
trying to make in this class which is
that it's the individual tendency to
deceive themselves to deceive ourselves
or to deceive oneself about the nature
of reality as it's defined personally
that constitutes the basic form of
Psychopathology that turns of the group
which is a necessary but dangerous
structure into something that's
pathologically
dangerous now the argument
basically I'll start we'll discuss that
argument today in a little bit more
detail but then I want to
flip to the last part of the course
which is a discussion of the process
that hopefully will serve as an
antithesis to this individual
pathology so you can describe you know
you can Define thing something very well
by describing its
opposite why we have anti-heroes in
literature at least in part because
they're good bad examples and you can
infer the opposite of something from a
description of that thing so it's
perfectly reasonable to start a
description
of identification with heroism I suppose
by discussing its opposite n said I
wrote a quote from him on page
2011 he said who alone has reason to lie
himself out of actuality and his answer
to that was he who suffers from it well
it's an interesting statement because
obviously it's not a description of an
individual person
or or a way of drawing a distinction
between those who lie and those who
don't really it's more a way of saying
that since it's obvious that everybody
suffers from
actuality that everyone has sufficient
motivation to
lie and what what we're going to try to
get out a little bit today again
is precisely what that motivation is
and then what the consequences the
inevitable consequences of following
that pattern of adaptation might
be I made the point last week that it's
it's difficult to get a picture of the
process that serves as the adversarial
counterpart to the mythological hero
because the reason that that process has
being described as a personality in
mythology is because it consists of a
number of a number of things
simultaneously it's difficult to discuss
something that consists of a number of
things simultaneously because when you
discuss anything you have to break it
down into its constituent elements then
you risk oversimplifying the personality
or reducing it to something to one
single thing that it's not and the
tendency to lie is a bunch of things at
once that are all interrelated and it
would be a mistake to try to reduce it
to a single thing but I think at least
in part
you can one of the essential aspects of
the tendency to lie is rejection of
error now there's a quote I'm going to
read you a quote from Milton he
describes Satan's
attitude and
uh I have a little comment on
that he says first which way I fly is
hail myself am hell and in the lowest
deep a lower deep still threatening to
devour me opens wide to which the hell I
suffer seems a heaven the devil whose
traditional representation of evil
refuses any recognition of imperfection
refuses to admit I was in error in my
action or in my
representation accepts as a consequence
of unbending Pride Eternal misery
refuses metanoia which is confession and
Reconciliation remains forever the
spirit that refuses and rejects is a
quote Oh then at last relent is there no
place left for repentance none for
pardon
left none left but by
submission and that word disdain forbids
me and my dread of Shame among the other
Spirits beneath whom I seduced with
other promises and other vs than to
submit boasting I could subdue the
omnipotent I me they little know how
dearly I abide that boast So Vain under
what torments inwardly I groan for they
adore me on the throne of hell with di
them and scepter High Advanced the lower
still I fall only Supreme in misery such
Joy ambition finds but say I could
repent and could obtain by Act of Grace
my former State how soon should height
recall High thoughts how soon unsay what
feain submission swore ease would recant
vows made in pain as violent and void
for never can true reconcile grow where
W wounds of deadly hate have pierced so
deep which would but lead me to a worse
relapse and heavier
fall so should I purchase deer short
intermission bought with double smart
this knows my Punisher therefore as far
from granting he as I from begging peace
all hope excluded
thus such refusal the inability to say I
was wrong I'm sorry I should change
means the death of Hope and existence in
the hellish of
Abyss right rejection of fact means
alienation from meaning from truth and
life without meaning is suffering
without recourse worthy of nothing but
destruction in accordance with
self-de so the
idea I guess what we're trying to do in
a sense is to unpack what rejection of
error means you already know from
looking at the the picture we put
together of the mythological portray
portrayal of reality but the that all
new information is gathered as a
consequence of contact with the unknown
I mean this is just a definition right
you can't gather anything any new
information unless you're somewhere that
you haven't been so to
speak you have to be in territory that's
unexplored to gather anything that's
novel now the problem with that from the
moral perspective so to speak since
we're dealing with with behavior and
emotion is that the only way that you
can get to be somewhere that you don't
know is by admitting to the existence of
anomalous to the existence of anomaly
and that's tanam to an admission that
you incorrect like the idea
being you have a vision of yourself and
where you are and you're contrasting
that with a vision of where you want to
be that's that's sort of your own
definition of what constitutes the world
and both of those polls are subject to
modification but you're the one who
decides what the polls are I mean you're
you're setting up the rules of the game
and then if by your own definition
your actions which are designed to bring
where you are to where you want to be
produce a contrary result that's
anomalous that's an anomalous piece of
information by your own definition see
you I I stress that because the problem
with talking about something like error
is that you might think that implicit in
that discussion is a notion that there's
some that you have to make recourse to
an idea of absolute truth to talk about
error but you don't like this model is
predicated on the notion that you Define
the terms of the argument for
yourself which is to say you're the one
who decides where you are and also where
you're going I mean you pull in
information from outside to make those
decisions of course but it's still your
game and if the actions that you've
constructed produce results that you
didn't intend that's what constitutes an
anomaly so it isn't that you have to
know anything about absolute truth so to
speak to determine when you are in fact
in error because you make the decisions
what if you get novel
information by establishing a
relationship with the unknown or an
aspect of the unknown and that
information that you get back in the
context of that relationship when it
contradicts information that's coming
from another source is the error so
rather than it rather than it being some
sort of
internal framework that you've
established for the things it's a
conflict between the meaning you're
getting from two different relationships
you have I would say that that's I I
would say that that's an equivalent
that's an equivalent phenomenon because
it is one of the examples I Us in the
text is the debate about abortion
because you can say well there's a lot
of emotional intensity surrounding the
abortion debate because it pits two
cultural schemas against the other
against one another one says the right
to life is
Paramount which is a perfectly valid
position and the other position says no
the right to Freedom right to free
choice is Paramount now under most
circumstances as most people in this
Society accept both of those uh moral
presuppositions but abortion happens to
be one situation assuming you know Good
Will on both sides so to speak that
happens to be one situation where the
phenomena the world presents us with
puts those two positions necessarily at
odds so then a third decision is
necessary which is the decision to
hierarchically arrange the two pres
presuppositions so it can be the case
that one philosophical stance that's
valid in most circumstances and another
valid in most circumstances to meet in a
third place and and War in opposition
then you get a situation where there's
there's an environmental
phenomena which would be the possibility
of unwanted birth or the possibility of
abortion that the two moral systems
which are modes of adaptation do not
properly address and then what happens
well that's the that's the eruption of
an anomalous occurrence into a cultural
structure and one of the things that
happens when that sort of thing happens
is that you get a war and there is a war
in this country between those two
positions it's just mostly still fought
at the level of words but not
always so that's the that's a conflict
of values and Yung said for example that
the most difficult moral decisions
always come about when there's a
conflict of
Duty one valid principle says action
pattern a another valid principle says
action pattern B the two action patterns
just justos produce an IR irreconcilable
situation then you then the question is
what do you do what can you do well
that's part of what we're going to get
at when we when we get to the end of the
argument
today if if it's impossible here and
it's impossible there what do you do
that's the question yeah I guess I was
wondering whether those two situations
are analogous but the emphasis is
slightly different whether you've got to
resolve it internally or whether you've
got to resolve it in the S of um
severing your connections with one of
those sources well that's that's an
option that's an option I mean I would
say one of the things we're going to
discuss today is consequences of
response patterns to anomalous
information and I would say well one
common way of dealing with the enormous
occurrence of that type is just to
fortify the position that you think is
most appropriate and exclude the rest
and that's a well it's that sort of
solution writ large in society that that
that I mean it has its advantages it's
protective but it's also that sort of
solution that taken to its extreme
causes causes the walls to rise up
around
communities one way of eliminating
anomalous information is to increase the
Conformity within the group and to put
more barriers up to stop information
from flowing in it's a good solution but
it has its problems so anyways is the
idea that all anomaly is personal has
experienced his personal error yes at
least that that's basically the idea
exactly is that the unknown actually
because the unknown the way that we're
construing it is a phenomena that
appears cloaked in affect it's always
necessarily making its appearance on the
scene of individual Consciousness so the
thing is you're acting out your moral
presuppositions which you have
determined by your own rules are the
ones you should act out then a piece of
information pops up its ugly head
suggesting that
your means are wrong or in a
catastrophic case the manner in which
you construe the present or your ends
are wrong in which case you're you're
really you're really in trouble
well the question is what then what do
you do then well that that's part of
what we're going to there's there's
three Alternatives I think one is that
you can you can
just pretend the anomalous thing never
happened and continue on in your path as
if the world wasn't the way you thought
it was when you know it not to be the
case that's one the other is to actively
take measures to get rid of the
anomalous
information that's a more extreme
variant of that first position the
second is to give up your whole moral
system and the underground advantage to
that is that moral systems are a pain in
a sense I mean they they have a
protective function certainly but to
adhere to them means that you have to
discipline your behavior
so I made a comment in there at one
point about the Dark Side of of
liberalism as well many comments about
the Dark Side of
conservatism one of the reasons to be
extraordinarily to welcome novel
information is so that you can dissolve
all those structures to which you might
have otherwise had to adhere the problem
with adhering to those structures is
that it takes a lot of work like if you
want to be an optimal member of any
given Society there's a whole structure
of discipline that's necessary to adhere
to and it's easy to to say I'm very
tolerant when actually what you mean is
I can't tolerate any of this
responsibility I'll just let it go and
everything's okay well you can get away
with that for a long time because
usually you're protected by other people
who are adhering to the rules and who
make sure that like the unior or make
sure that you stay
alive so
okay well the okay
so this argument always Loops back onto
itself because the processes are
actually can only be described as in
terms of a feedback so it's very
difficult to get a handle on the origin
of the story so to say so to speak
but why would you reject the appearance
of anous information so animals don't
seem to do that well the argument that
I've been trying present is that as nii
pointed out we all have a reason to lie
nii said well why would you bother lying
Yourself by an actuality his answer was
well because you suffer from it that's a
good answer well that's a a one-
sentence description of the process that
I was trying to describe in the chapter
on the development of self-consciousness
the problem for human beings is that
well even for Animals the appearance of
an anomalous piece of information is
sufficient to activate the right frontal
cortical circuitry that governs negative
aect that's right an anomalous
occurrence stops you in your tracks so
if you're a rabbit and you're hopping
along in the bush and you hear a noise
that shouldn't be there or you see a
shape that's moving like a predator what
will happen to you that's something that
should not be what will happen to
you is that you'll freeze right because
the systems that govern anxiety and
inhibition of behavior gripped have
gripped your cortical apparatus same
thing happens in people our first resp
responds to an anomalous event is
anxiety and the cessation of ongoing
Behavior which is exactly how it should
be because if an anomalous event occurs
it's it indicates by its very nature
that the plan you are undertaking is
wrong because otherwise the anomalous
piece of information wouldn't have
showed up but the problem with us is
that the whole domain of anomaly which
can be conceptualized as a place and is
conceptualized that way in mythology is
contaminated by our knowledge of the the
potential consequences of error and
those consequences I mean you can kind
of divide them into two
counts one price of admission of error
is that you have to regard yourself as
less than the group that you've
identified with which is to say that you
look like a fool in front of people who
theoretically you want respect and
admiration prop those can be actual
people or they can be the people that
live in your head so to speak the super
ego person person bifi doesn't really
matter either way it's the same thing
you have to recognize yourself as less
than you might be that's one consequence
and people are very terrified about that
we don't like exposure of our weaknesses
in front of the social group even Freud
pointed out in his interpretation of
Dreams the common anxiety dream was to
appear naked in front of a crowd which
is basically to say to expose your
vulnerability to to the world or to have
that vulnerability accidentally exposed
when you make a fool of someone that's
exactly what you're doing it's like they
have pretentions which are their plans
you just twist them the plans fall and
you see the person behind the plant
while they turn red and turn away
because their vulnerability has been
made manifest to the group and also to
themselves it's very unpleasant
occurrence that's shame in part so
that's one reason the other reason is
that for us the whole domain of anomally
has a is contaminated by the threat of
mortality which is something that's not
true for animals at all because anim
can't conceive of themselves as an
object that faces these extreme
limitations the limitations of mortality
so we have real reason to turn away from
anomaly you know you want to make it
concrete for example you wake up in the
morning and you know you have an ache in
your side well that ache which is an
anomalous piece of information since
you're always acting to as a general
rule at least mean if you worked out the
gym the night before you have a ready
made reason and the a is bounded by an
explanation and its affective veilance
is basically zero I mean you might be a
little stiff that day in favor the side
but you're not going to walk around in
the state of Terror if you have no
readymade explanation for the anomaly
then there's an un there's an it has an
unbounded potential significance now
under normal circumstances you you would
like to think well it isn't all that
serious I'll go on with my life and see
what happens if you're hypochondrial
which means
that well it means you're it's easy for
you to blow things out of proportion
you're allow your fantasy to which is a
hypothesis generating machine to work on
providing potential explanations for the
ache which might range from I slept
wrong to this is the incipient incipient
sign of the cancer that will kill me I
know someone for example whose father
and grandfather both died of a heart
attack when they were in the
neighborhood of 40 and he's
35 and he's is borderline AGR phobic
which basically means that he can't
tolerate any fluctuations in his heart
rate because that's one of the signs of
agobia people of AGR phobia if their
heart rate goes up they tend to think oh
no you know this is the event that will
either lead me to make a fool of myself
or that will kill me well he's in the
situation that's very much like that all
the time because every time he feels
some unexplained internal event thinks
you know that's the end of me well you
can see his you can see why he would be
neurotic in a situation like that I mean
he has good reason for doubting the int
for doubting the the easy explanations
for the existence of this anomalous
information because you know heart
disease is
hereditary he's a little overweight he
drinks a little bit too much he smokes a
little bit too much he works too hard is
good reason for being afraid but that's
the sort of thing that an animals never
going to experience because an animal
can't use its cortex against its limic
system in which is something weak what
your cortex is supposed to do your
frontal cortex basically but an
anomalous piece of information pops up
your frontal cortex is supposed to map
out a behavioral pattern that eliminates
the veilance from the phenomena but
sometimes you can't do that because your
frontal cortex basically says oh no this
might be the thing that exposes my
weaknesses to the group or kills me in
which case your lyic system responds to
that labeling as if that in itself is
threat and out of control you go which I
think is an for panic attack phenomena
for example it's catastrophic reasoning
but everybody has like for me the ex for
me the mystery of panic attacks is more
why people just don't have them all the
time really really because the people
who have them have good reason for
having them but those reasons are very
much like the reasons that we all
have
so we're lucky is the answer I think
under most circumstances it's
like we're protected by by our implicit
theories of belief or our implicit
systems of
belief and most of us I suppose were
taught as children if a minor physical
anomaly arises that the best course of
action is to carry on at least as a mode
of hypothesis
testing that's a form that's a form
acquired adaptation sounds also like
willing to consider alternative
explanation
might what protect us
from well that's sure and that's one of
the things you teach in cognitive beh
behavioral therapy which is but the
thing is most of us are lucky you see
with most people who are neurotic if you
provide them with an alternative
explanation that they find plausible it
has no impact whatsoever on their
symptomatology so you take someone who's
obsessive compulsive disorder for
example can't which is often manifested
in fear of contamination so here's the
line of logic There's a garbage can
garbage can stand are dirty dirt
contains bacteria bacteria might kill me
or worse my children so this is an
example drawn from a case that I know
University educated woman nothing wrong
with her intelligence perfectly normal
unless she was encountered something
that was contaminated you do response
prevention treatment which is that you
have the person encounter the thing that
they fear the most and then stop them
from doing their habitual response
patterns which for her was washing her
hands until they were so raw they were
shiny anyways um she thought that there
was a possibility that if she
encountered something that was
contaminated which was a category that
got broader and broader as her disease
progressed that she'd carry home a
disease to her children now the problem
see the problem with that line of
reasoning is that it's possible and you
could say to her and she could
understand that the probability of such
an event occurring was virtually zero
but the fact of virtually zero was not
sufficiently uh satisfying for that to
calm her because
0.001% was too much so you couldn't
rationally reduce the probability to to
a small enough degree so that her
thought of that probability could
regulate her emotions and the only
reason we don't know why those sorts of
thoughts regulate our emotions so you're
willing to accept it on faith for
whatever reason you jump in a
car do all sorts of things that are
dangerous without any real consideration
of it I knew another woman who was agrob
first thing she used to do when she went
into new building what she didn't like
doing check out all the fire escapes why
there might be a fire right there might
be a fire what's the probability well
it's low she knew that she knew that the
probability was low just like the rest
of us know but the capacity of that
information to inhibit her anxiety was
gone the only thing you can do under
those circumstances is actually have
people act out not caring then then than
that works but don't some don't some
people AR that her her rationalization
that there might be a f her behavior is
something that comes after her behavior
and not something that causes her in
other words could is it is it necessary
couldn't it be one of two things either
she she enters the building and thinks
my my goodness there there could be fire
I have to check fire escapes or maybe
she walks into a building her anxiety
Rises and she says I have to check the
sure sure that's r no no that that's
possible some of these explanations are
post Hawk rationalization
it's hard to tell like I'm not try toy a
caal sequence what happens in agobia
think is the behavioral avoidance Tak
over the cognitive rationalization
whatever they are what happens to the
AGR phobic is they go to the mall
something frightening happens and they
run away now it's the running away that
constitutes the point of origin for the
pathology now they may say I ran away
because you know here's my set of
cognitive rationalizations many of which
might be post talk explanations for my
behavior but the thing is when you run
from something what you are doing
regardless of what you're thinking is
labeling it as something so frightening
that I have to run away from and that's
the most profound level of labeling that
you can actually utilize it's it's much
more real than you know the secondary or
even tertiary semantic labeling that we
usually associate with categorization to
run from something means to categorize
it as too frightening to be to bear and
and also one one more thing it also
means to categorize
yourself and this is even more important
as something that's so small that in
that situation the only thing that can
be done is to run away and the reason
that exposure therapy works is I think
mostly because it it counters that
latter argument which is that when
you when you teach someone exposure when
you use exposure to help someone
overcome their fears what you are doing
is teaching them that they're not so
small that fear will devour them and
that's what caus is the generalization
it's learning that so's also Prof social
expectations in a situation absolutely
absolutely no I the therapist uses
modeling and social pressure and
everything else to to Foster the notion
that the person can withstand the
exposure C can I just translate
something back that that I that I seem
to be hearing in a sense from what you
said today so far if if I may it seems
as if the the thing that protects us
from pathology the ability to to
attribute multiple meanings to something
the ability that our pral cortex gives
us is the same thing that can cause a
problem also if you've
gots you've got a conflict and
absolutely absolutely I think well any
religious myths for example myths of the
Fall State fundamentally that the
development of
self-consciousness which is associated
with a tremendous expansion of cortical
ability plus the ability to model the
self as an object precipitated that
catastrophe an emotional catastrophe but
the cure for the catastrophe is more of
the same
disease right so it's the problem is
that a little self-consciousness is
terrible a lot however might might be
Redemptive and that's the notion that it
underlies well it underlies all sorts of
Redemptive mythology and that's the
notion that's underlying the argument
that I'm trying to elaborate up today is
that if you know
enough about
yourself then the consequences of a of a
narrow self-consciousness can be remove
and I would say well what myths are
trying to teach you as if they're trying
to teach you something which they're
really not I mean they're just there
what they're trying to teach you is that
your normal conception of who you are is
much too narrow now you know at some
level you know that's true because
you're model of yourself wrong obviously
because you're too complex for yourself
to
model it's like no one thinks that they
have an accurate model of cosmological
processes and it's certainly arguable
that the processes that make up each of
us as individuals are
complex at a level that's exponentially
greater than any cosmological process
that we could possibly conceive of so
the notion that your model of yourself
is inaccurate that's just a statement of
fact the part that's not so fact is how
you can get valid information to
increase the breadth of that model and
what I'm basically trying to point out
is that mythology can do that because
what myth is in large
part is our accumulative attempt to
construct a story that accounts for our
behavior in the world that's right we
watch ourselves act and derive
conclusions as a consequence if you're
severely neurotic enough that like your
entire life is a lie and everything that
happens to you even though you recognize
it is bad and you're miserable and
you're full of Despair and have no hope
if it's always from some outside cause
and never resign with
yourself what what what's intrinsically
rewarding about lying to yourself if you
know that you're making yourself
miserable because I know because look
any defined terror is better than any
undefined Terror because a defined
Terror has a boundary and an undefined
Terror has none and that's the here's an
example there's been some reliable
studies of late that indicate that gay
men who engage in highrisk behavior for
AIDS are less anxious after being
diagnosed with AIDS than they were
before because the possibility the
possibility is worse than the actuality
no matter how bad the actuality is the
possibility is worse but what about if
you're neurotic because of Pride and not
fear like if it's just I think those
that that's always the case as far as
I've been able to determine it's not
that's why I said you you can't say this
is just one thing these things
conglomerate together the people that
I've dealt with who were severely
neurotic enough so that their whole life
was a lie and literally it was Pride as
well that was stopping them from letting
go they wouldn't say oh look Jung said
for example he T he treated one patient
who had a obsessional Neurosis that
lasted 20 years he said I cannot
reconcile myself to the fact that I
wasted the best years of my life
say think of what that admission
requires say you know you have a finite
time and if you've blown not only have
you blown out a big chunk of it but in
the course of blowing it out you've
you've added to the cumulative misery of
the world you know lots of people who
are non phys physiologically unhealthy
use their neurotic misery to manipulate
others around them to their own ANS to
make people feel guilty to get them to
do what they want because they don't
think they can just come right out and
say you know would you please do this
they have to manifest some sign of
weakness so that they force other people
to take care of them all of that has to
come up and be admitted before you can
step away from this
situation what was Satan afraid of then
he had all eternity all like he had
nothing more to lose everything to gain
he could have said sorry oops and gets
gotten sucked back into heaven like
where did Pride become fear for Satan in
Paradise Lost I can't answer I don't
know I like I don't know enough to
answer that question specifically I mean
the only thing I can the only thing I
can say about that is that these
processes feed back onto one another I
mean the more look okay let me go
through this argument to some degree and
maybe it'll maybe it'll shed a little
bit of light on that question
okay what happens what's the consequence
of rejection of error well we know that
before you can engage in any sort of
creative exploration you have to at
least admit that something went wrong
right so you say well there's something
wrong with my model at some level of
analysis that's the admission then the
next process is to engage in some sort
of creative exploration which is
basically the generation of hypothesis
and they're testing right you find out
if you made someone upset for example
accidentally well then you think well
maybe this was wrong with my Approach
and then you talk to the person about
that see if that was right and if that
wasn't you throw that hypothesis aside
think up another one and act it see if
you get the information you want and so
on and so forth till you get the answer
that's creative exploration say what
happens as a consequence of creative
exploration well look remember we talked
about symbols of the chaos that existed
prior to the creation of the world so to
speak that chaos symbolized by the
dragon as a general rule is composed of
the Union of all things that are now
opposite it's the source of all things
not just objects but subjects as well so
it's everything that we see as distinct
melded into some paradoxical unity and
that stands for the unknown as such now
P said when children that children
construct themselves as a consequence of
their creative exploration which
basically means that the child doesn't
know anything about the world it's a
very bounded domain of knowledge what it
does is encounter the vast
unknown
explore generate information and out of
that information constructs itself as a
subject which means grants itself a self
and also the world as an objective
reality so that's what the notion that
chaos also contains the subject means is
that as you gather it if you build
yourself out of the information you
generate in the process of
exploration if you stop exploring well
that has obvious conclusions doesn't it
means you stop building yourself we
already know that A system that stops
growing
of its because everything around the
system changes of its own accord decays
over time and we know what the Decay
means means life comes to a standstill
and the negative forces that are
underneath order rise up so that story
basically says reject anomaly your
personality stops developing then you're
in the the kingdom that's come to a
standstill where everything's paralyzed
there's no water everything's dying well
what that means is that the mere fact of
not progressing
means that you go backwards and your
life becomes as those a desert nothing
grows in the desert everything's
unbearable there so you say if you
reject the possibility of growth what
necessarily occurs is that all that's
left for you is a life that gets worse
and worse and worse and worse and worse
now if your life goes from bad to worse
over
time well we know already this is this
addresses the comment you made last
week if you punish an animal you make it
mean that's one way it Mak it mean
anyways if you construct your
relationship with the world such that
over time the likelihood is that
everything will go from bad to worse the
other consequence of that is that your
attitude towards your existence is going
to go from bad to worse as well you say
why do people why are people consumed
with hatred and the desire for Revenge
which is played out you know completely
in Milton's
Story Once Satan determines that
admission of error is completely out of
the question he turns his attention to
taking revenge on
existence I'm trying to expl trying to
provide an explanation for why that's a
necessary consequence of this because if
you stop if you eliminate a priority the
necessity for further growth deny
yourself the possib ility of positive
change and adaptation the necessary
consequence of that is increased
personal suffering and it's very likely
given that you're narrowing your
personality which means you get weaker
and weaker it's very very likely under
those circumstances that you're going to
become more and more full of Revenge
because life's so unfair after all and
hatred because you're always being
tortured even though you're doing it to
yourself I mean the rationalization is
why do all these terrible things
constantly happen to me it must either
be that everyone's against me which is a
perfectly common hypothesis or that the
conditions of existence itself are so
unbearable that everything should be
eradicated which as we talked about last
week is the essential that's the
essential Credo of mephastophilis right
the world is so intrinsically so
unbearable that the only proper course
of action is to work for its
elimination last week I tried to talk
that to tie that into stell's reasoning
basically because that's it looks to me
like that was the philosophy that
characterizes Stell everyone's against
me that's for sure he was a real
paranoid and he worked throughout his
life to continually develop his capacity
to destroy larger and larger swamps of
people what differ is that person from
someone who wants to kill like what
makes a difference that they want to
other I don't think there's much
difference really um if life is so
unbearable why wouldn't they just see I
think like this is not always the case
because suicide is motivated by all
sorts of different reasons but it's
certainly the case and I I think this is
particularly true about adolescent
suicide is that it's an act of Revenge
because well it and it also is an
illustration of How deep the motivation
for Revenge can be because adolescent
suicidal fantasies are often go along
the lines of of oh won't all those
people be sorry when I'm gone and then
there's a whole fantasy about how the
funeral will progress and all these
people who've paid insufficient
attention or being otherwise cruel will
file by and think about all the Terrible
Things They did so on and so forth and
well the truth of the truth of the
matter is that the suicide leaves a hole
in a community that can't be reconciled
because the people who are left over are
always faced with the question of why
did this happen and also what could I
have done about it both of which are
essentially unanswerable so
the the question that you're posing to
some degree is is one murder worse than
a million or and I would say they don't
sum in a sense just as you know just as
you our society is predicated on the
idea that every individual is of
incalculable worth well you can't one
thing of incalculable worth is worth as
much as 20 things of incalculable worth
so it's not it's not an additive
phenomenon so I think the same sort of
thing
the vengeful aspect motivates both the
Newman ER Newman conceptualized suicide
is he thought that was the mythological
expl explanation was regressive wish for
incest with the great mother which is a
very awkward way of saying if only I was
gone if only I vanished back to the
point that I had come from then all of
these problems that I faced with would
just disappear and that's that's also
something that's charact and
Newman imagined that in a sense
as an attractive Force pulling someone
down below the Earth so that's a that's
a desire for death as a as a solution to
the problems of life you could also say
these things are complicated you can
also say that gong thought that the
collective unconscious produced
compensatory fantasies which basically
meant that if your conscious mind so to
speak which was in part your
linguistically constructed self was
failing to take certain possibilities
into account than the collective
unconscious which you might think about
as manifesting itself in fantasies that
you really can't control that just pop
up like fantasies of death for example
often although they may have a
pathological aspect they also hold out
at least in possibility the seeds of a
cure because you could say well if
you're
here and you're convinced that this is
unbearable the notion that a death is
necessary is a A first order attempt to
hypothesize that the thing that
constrains your interpretation of
meaning should disappear which is to say
that the fact that your life is become
so Twisted that you regard it as
unbearable is evidence that your mode of
interpretation is so outdated that it
should die now that's a perfectly
reasonable that's that's a sacrificial
Motif right I read the other
day I didn't know this that the idea of
sacrificing a finger is very common
throughout archaic mythology I didn't
know
that well a finger is something that's
very important it's the same idea as the
sacrifice of a virgin or the sacrifice
of the hero that if things are
unbearable you either have to kill
what's making it unbearable so that
something new can come into being that's
one mode of the sacrificial btif but the
other thing is is other thing that
underlies the sacrificial Motif is the
idea of the exposure of the hero to the
forces of the
unknown right that's another sacrifice
so on that diagram this one yeah it
doesn't matter back up um new
basically suicide it's like returning to
the source of all things like returning
to the wound right because that that
unconscious chaos that precedes
existence has a paradisal aspect right
because there's no tension of opposites
there which basically means there's just
no being at all but which can be a
relief you know under certain conditions
so is that it I'm just saying within
that framework is that would you say
that's um heading into chaos or is that
going back um along diagram well it
depends you
see if you move from border like where's
where's the source of all things where's
the great can we put the great mother
within that diagram yeah sure sure look
no problem this is anomalous information
here so you say well chaos is unknown as
such you never encountered that because
you always encounter things that are
more or less within a determinant
framework you never see what you don't
understand in its entirety or maybe that
occurs to people who are having a m some
sort of mystical experience mostly what
you see are things that you can somewhat
Define that pop up in your day-to-day
experience those are actual anomalous
pieces of information that you have some
definitional handle on well the great
mother would be the sorry
here you can think of the great mother
as the agent of chaos which is a
perfectly reasonable way to look at it
because in the mythological progression
she's the first off right Thea the
original chaos separates into the great
mother and the great father right so she
is the first child of chaos so is she a
subset essentially of chaos like within
that she's the form of the form that
chaos takes in your actual
experience so wouldn't it be more
accurate in that diagram to say that
chaos there is what chaos is the great
mother there because what he's going
back to well you have to he's talking
about that's where the entire diagram
comes from because that's the world
before it split into yeah but it's comp
it's complicated because for example
many figures of the great mother have a
snake wrapped around them well that's
because the the association between the
dragon of chaos and the great mother is
very very close so to say this is the
great mother is true but it's not just
that it's also the origin of the great
father and also the origin of the hero
so the fig look mythological figures are
contaminated by each other because
they're not tight categories so lots of
like the Gorgon is another example great
mother her hair is snakes which is a
representative of chaos now when you
look at her you turn to Stone which
means that you're terrified so she's an
agent of chaos but chaos is more that
that first order category is more than
just the kind of anomaly that you
encounter in your day-to-day life it's
the source of
everything so it's outside the whole
process okay okay I was just saying I
mean I know that this the symbols mesh
together on that level but if we're if
we're bringing them into a more
systematic framework yeah
then to to kill yourself I mean to
eliminate the self entirely would
essentially be to send yourself into
into nothing into what where everything
came from right right exactly so which
is somewhat different from what you
encounter if that if that is the diagram
of the way we encounter life then well
iide well I would say that the things
that make you desire a return to
nothingness are the the actual anomalous
phenomena threatening phenomena that
you've encountered like the sum total of
all of them so it's repeated appearances
of Intolerable information produce
within you the desire to to vanish
basically
so anyways the figures the figures are
contaminated that's why time at for
example in the in the Mesopotamian myth
me absu he's the known in the
Mesopotamian myth right the consort of
the time he gets very little press in
that story what four lines devoted to
him the gods kill him stupidly and of
course then tat Rises up right because
he's the thing that protected them from
tat but that's all that's known about
him really tat is female and the wife of
ABS and the mother of Marduk but she's
also the serpent that lies at the bottom
of the ocean that's the mother of
everything the source of everything so
there you can see the overlap between
the mythological domain she's female but
she's also a serpent she lives at the
bottom of the ocean
so did new
notion of what suicide was based on the
fantasies of people who later would come
on to commit suicide or did he just
follow a train of reasoning to decide
that suicide was desire for in I don't
know the I don't know the details of the
conclusion he came to he wasn't
practicing therapist um is it possible
he got so excited about the system that
he was pulling together sure that's
always possible that's it's just it's
more a story it's more a way of looking
looking at the situation I mean it's
not it's not unreasonable to suppose
that people who commit suicide wish for
the cessation of their experience I mean
since that's what suicide produces as
well as a lot of generally a lot of
misery on the part of people left behind
one like there's a psychoanalytic this
is a union accent actually uh okay if
you can't tell what motivates a behavior
look at the effects the effects are the
are what motivated it now you say that's
a pretty extreme position it is an
extreme position but I'll tell you if
you part that to your own life it
produces very interesting consequences
at least as a horis like you can say no
that's not always true fine it's not
always true but if you do something and
it has a certain effect and you say well
I didn't intend that effect and you ask
why did I do that A first order
hypothesis a useful first order
hypothesis is I did intend that but I
didn't know it and if you follow that
line of reasoning it can it well it can
have some have very salutary effects
especially if the thing that you didn't
intend has happened like two or three
times because then it's there's some
indication that of complicity if it's
only one occurrence well you know
mistakes happen but if it keeps
happening to
you I think the other statement was if
if it's pointing a gun at you it's
likely that it wants to shoot you the
same sort of idea that was in reference
to the Cold War it's like why were
people conspiring to build weapons to
destroy the world well the simple I
maybe too simple explanation is at some
level that was the intent well I I buy
that argument it certainly appeared to
be stell's intent I mean he was
practicing it all the time now the
question is how much was that the intent
of the West well that's not answerable
yet but I would suspect to a large
degree does that same reasoning apply to
other people's behavior well it's
dangerous to apply to other people's
behavior
but look it isn't a principle that I
rely on as an absolute explanation but
it's a useful hypothesis especially like
I said the same thing keeps happening
say you like you Elizabeth you made the
point you know neurotic people will will
find themselves trapped in in in misery
that they recognize clearly as misery
without stepping outside of it and I
would say
well that that fact indicates that they
prefer the misery they have to the
possibilities they don't have see it's
the only way to explain or it's not the
only way to explain anything but it's
one way of accounting for the fact of
resistance in Psychotherapy isn't it
also true like in Notes From The
Underground where the point is made that
suffering is fun because like it gets
tension and oh sure that's that's that's
the secondary gain hypothesis there's
that's it's an effective manipulative
strategy has all sorts of of of
self-reinforcing uh side effects I mean
that's why it occurs rejection of
anomali is very negatively reinforcing
that's one of the reasons why it's well
it has this attractive aspect so if you
don't attend to all those things that
indicate that you're in error I mean to
the degree that you're successful and
not attending to them you're not anxious
you're not depressed you're not confused
you know but the problem is is all that
information that you don't process first
of all isn't transformed by you into
something usable and second of all as
far as I've been able to tell it
accumulates over time and and then what
happens to you is that you're getting
smaller and smaller just because that's
the way things work basically if you
stagnate you get sicker and sicker and
the things that you yourself have
labeled as threatening because you when
you refuse to process something what
you're saying or what you're doing is
that thing is too terrible for me to
contemplate so what you're doing is
transforming chunks of the world into
the category of
those things that are too terrifying to
contemplate or you're leaving them in
that category which is a more accurate
way of looking at it you know sooner
later you're this High and the world
that you've transformed into threat is
everywhere around you and it's only a
matter of time until you're weak enough
so that the whole the whole thing Falls
in on you is there a difference between
ignoring it and just interpreting it in
such a way like the positive bias
phenomenon where nothing is ever your
fault and like you're the Martyr like
anything bad that happens to you is
because there's some evil for out there
that way you're kind of taking it in
only you're putting such a spin on it
that you're saying here's this unknown
thing I'm making it known but I'm
labeling it wrong on purpose that way
well that's just a that's just a variant
of the same theme but it accumulates
well I think worse and worse because
it's a it's a it's a it's a feedback
mechanism that's right there's a
feedback mechanism at work so because
you get smaller and smaller yeah and you
mislabeled the problem well well
actually I think really what you're
doing is that you're you're not pulling
the label off it because we already know
that anomalous information manifests
itself as threat that's right that's how
your right frontal cortex Works
basically mistake comes up in the form
of threat that's how it's indicated well
then so it's already labeled as threat
your job when you explore is to
transform the threat into something
irrelevant or something beneficial not
to merely label it as something
different but to actually change it by
altering your behavior into something
that it's usable if you don't do that
well then what's happening is that the
determinant World transforms itself back
into terrifying chaos and you're just
failing to stop that from happening
it'll do that all by itself but by
labeling it an evil force you may then
take effort to get rid of the evil force
and thereby make it even worse that's
true that's certainly at least worse for
others and I would say well also worse
yourself yes yes oh that's right I mean
I but there's more motiv to that because
as you're weakening yourself and your
hatred for life grows your desire for
Revenge accelerates so that then if you
could take the next step and say well
not only is this anomalous information
intolerable but it's evil then I can
kill it well then you've got everything
said because you can remove the source
of your trouble you can act out your
hostile fantasies and you can feel
Justified because you're patriotic or
which is all just it's a
rubbish um yeah like know you're talking
about
and um the world is so terrible that it
must be destroyed is it possible to
distinguish that from like the world is
so terrible fascism of it must be
destroyed or we need oh yes I would say
sure absolutely that's distinguishable
because one of the Hallmarks of the hero
and this is something that that I I was
kind of at pains to outline in the
latter part of this manuscript is the
hero has two functions one is to
transform transform unexplored territory
into explored territory which is just
Mard battle against time but also to
update the social structure which is
both manifested internally and
externally as that becomes necessary so
the pro now we know the problem with
updating a social structure is that
sometimes that takes on a
revolutionary aspect and then for all
the adherence of that social structure
who are undergoing a forced Revolution
that heroic activity is going to seem
like a demonic demonic Force that's why
people are so irritated at Heretics
that's right because they pop up
anomalous information and for good
reason I mean careless hereis is very
very dangerous because it produces
schismatic activity and breaks societies
down but it also it's like a genetic
mutation that's the best that's the best
metaphor I know it's like 999
revolutions are counterproductive but
the one revolution in a thousand that
isn't counterproductive is absolutely
necessary and the problem is how do you
distinguish between the two I mean if if
you just use the odds the first thing
you'd say is all revolutionaries should
be regarded with skepticism like extreme
skepticism but not skepticism to the
point where a priority they should be
eliminated because one of them just
might be well just might be the
hero
so
comment
yeah I I'm I'm still trying trying to
translate what you're talking about into
of framework and the what I was just
thinking of is there might be two ways
to change the social system one by
coming back as an heretic and advocating
okay the way things should be telling
people what beliefs should replace the
ones to have the other way is to come
back changed right right right yes and
then your relationship with other people
change in well that's that's that's the
sort of the sort of path that that well
that I want to outline in more detail
next week because it one I think one one
piece of evidence that should justify
skepticism is the overt desire of the
Revolutionary to maintain their position
at all cost and to transform everyone
around them because then you think was
that Revolution or is that like is that
fascism masquerading his Revolution
which it almost always is so like a
communist ideologue who wants to
transform a capitalist Society isn't
revolutionary it's just a he's just a
fascist on the left wing you know
there's no heroism in that and I guess I
suppose the other thing that one might
be skeptical of is revolutionaries in
groups because that's sort of a
contradiction in terms right so not
always for either of those but that's
still a sign I would say but I think
that the notion of coming back change
that's the issue like I think what these
myths are trying to point out is that
the only permanently effective form of
social Revolution is a personal
Revolution that then just acts itself
out where and that social change is just
a necessary consequence of that personal
change it isn't something that's being
enforced or even planned out to all that
degree it's
just I me know that strikes me as I like
a that strikes me as a justifiable
position at least then you're also much
less likely to make catastrophic errors
because your primary concern is always
what am I doing wrong or here's the
situation how am I contributing to it
not you know where are all the bad
people who are really causing all the
trouble so I mean I knew lots of this is
kind of sarcastic comment I guess but I
knew lots of environmental activists in
graduate school who lived in filthy
Apartments know it's like they couldn't
even keep their personal territory clean
and yet they were willing to engage in
activities that in terms of their own
fantasies had the potential impact of
restructuring
Society Practice What You Preach well at
least yeah at least at least act it out
so that you can see on your own
territory one if it works and two if you
can actually even act it out so the
thing is well you know there's myth
funny mythological statements like the
man who rules himself is has has uh I
don't know the quote precisely the man
who rules himself has performed a more
difficult task than the man who rules a
city H was that it's hard to rule a city
what it means is it is actually the
truth it's you're much more complicated
phenomena than a city and to bring
yourself under some sort of control is
much more difficult
than it's it's more difficult than
bringing a given social structure under
control because the social structure is
simple in comparison plus it's also
equivalent to bringing a social
structure under control because what
you're composed of in large part is the
sum total of social structures as they
as they've been generated over immense
stretches of time so inside your for
example like if you want to reconcile
the abortion debate that's an internal
reconciliation as well you have to
rethink the philosophical
presuppositions sufficiently deep enough
so that you come to a solution that
brings the two sides together that can
only take place inside before it takes
place outside at all has
to at some level don't don't most
powerful social movements bring these
two things together um like the um vow
of not drinking in the early days of
solidarity which was one of the things
that really impressed me about it in
Poland was a way it translated to acts
of personal transformation or the the
way in which the Civil Rights Movement
evolved in this country requiring um
personal change uh which was through a
in a collective way created social
change uh or in the women's movement uh
I mean in other words it seems like in
these gen social movements change occurs
both at a macro and micro level they're
brought they're they're in conidence
with one another well I mean that's that
strikes me at least as a plausible
hypothesis you know um I remember um
George Orwell right he was he started
out as a socialist ideologically but
then well what one one of the things
that transformed him from a mere
ideologue to a writer of note and a
political commentator of note was that
he decided he noted that um in his
experience most academic socialists
weren't all that fond of the poor this
was particularly true in Britain where
there's a hierarchical class structure
so they were from the upper classes and
acted out their detestment of the lower
classes in all their action patterns
while holding the ideological belief
that the poor were in fact morally
Superior so what Orwell did was well he
went to Paris in London and lived in
Paris among
dishwashers and in in Great Britain
among traps and coal miners forcing
himself self to overcome what he soon
recognized was a very deep set prejudice
against everything that the poor
represented well then that what happened
to Orwell was he dropped his socialism
very rapidly because he found that the
ideological structure was nowhere near
profound enough to Encompass what he'
experienced plus it had you know
enormously dangerous side effects which
he increasingly came to recognize so
maybe I mean maybe that's a maybe that's
because one of the things that everyone
would like to figure out is like how do
you distinguish
a pathological Revolution from a valid
Revolution and I mean I would say if
you're asking someone else to Bear more
of the costs than you're actually
bearing then that's one sign that it's
that there's some sort of pathology at
the bottom of it who knows but that
seems like a reasonable first
approximation so I guess you also have
to see like who gets what out of it and
the Communist Revolution as far as I've
been able to determine just replaced one
tyrannical group that at least were were
Bound by tradition with another
tyrannical group that were completely
Unbound by tradition and and even more
tyrannical I
mean because the problem was is
that the re the only
reason the Russian revolutionaries were
more moral than the Zar was because they
didn't have any power you know they
couldn't do anything so they looked to
themselves more I'm harmless look I mean
I put anybody in prison of course they
don't have a prison you know
but well when they got prisons they
certainly put lots of people
in
so other
comments okay Daniel no okay
so yeah okay so we basically got to this
point in the argument now what is that a
diagram on the board
which what are you doing oh I'm just
outlining this arum so that I don't
forget where I am basically it goes like
this up over here
so okay so the question is how to get
out of
this I mean if we're willing to take an
each's notion seriously which is that
everyone has sufficient reason to lie
and the question is you know given that
as a premise the conclusion is perhaps
to a much larger degree than we
believe we are lying to ourselves now
one of the thing Shelley Taylor She's
the social psychologist who's been
promoting this positive self-illusion uh
notion one of the valuable things she's
done I think was although I don't think
she drew the right conclusion from it
was that she noted that many people who
we regard as normal and healthy do in
fact erect around themselves barriers of
positive
Illusions now she Drew from that the
conclusion that to be normal and healthy
well first of all that normal people
were healthy which is a I have a real
problem with that but I mean you can see
you can see how that necessarily emerges
as a consequence of psychological
methodology in a sense because
okay I made the argument to begin with
in the class that as soon as you apply a
field like psychology or medicine you're
out of the domain of Science and into
the domain of morality because you have
to make judgments about what constitutes
the good you have to now but people who
are in the domain of science don't like
to admit that so they try to figure out
ways to determine what's moral
scientifically without ever having to
address the problem and the easiest way
to do that is by saying well here's the
normal distribution right the optimal
level is the midpoint so you take the
average person you see how many positive
self- Illusions they have around them
you say those average people they're
normal that defines healthy therefore
positive self elusions are necessary
well this is like this is a real problem
because first of all many things that
are average we don't consider ideal I
that's why the two words exist in
opposition we don't strive for average
intelligence or average athletic ability
or average beauty or average
accomplishment at any level we're always
moving towards some sort of Ideal anyway
so I think Shelley Taylor got caught in
her own trap in a sense she got caught
in her own unconscious presuppositions
and said well normal people have to be
healthy by definition normal people have
lots of positive self- Illusions
therefore positive self- elusions are
necessary there's lots of flaws in that
argument you I I by the her argument
that many people who are considered
normal by normal standards erect
barriers of self of positive Illusions
around themselves but the fact that they
do that is no indication whatsoever that
it's necessary or
desirable the argument that I've been
trying to outline in this whole course
is
that to the degree that the members of a
soci to the degree that a me the members
of a society erect positive self-
Illusions around themselves to protect
their normality they will make their
group pathological the more pathological
it gets the more likely it is to like do
something terrible to other groups the
sickness is going to come out
somewhere our our time scale analysis in
Psychology is something really that we
don't ever question it's like you know a
given phenomena can have a beneficial
effect at
at the level of analysis of a minute a
detrimental effect if you look at its
effect over the course of a day a mildly
beneficial effect if you look at it over
the course of a week you know a
tremendously detrimental effect if you
look at it over the course of a year the
same thing can have all sorts of
different effects depending on your
parameters of evaluation and generally
psychologists pick one parameter of
evaluation and say well that's
representative of the whole temporal
framework and that's just it's not a
justifiable conclusion say
people who are high in self-deception
may appear more psychological
psychologically healthy in the short
term if you Define psychological Health
as the absence of anxiety and depression
in the short term but you don't know
anything about what that means for their
interpersonal Behavior you don't know
anything about what that means you don't
know anything about what that means for
the course of their lifespan or for
their children you have no idea what it
means for the relationships with the
group or between groups so until you
answer all those questions you know you
have to be pretty careful about
saying about making as radical a claim
as self-deception is necessary for
psychological Health can we what types
of
self-deceptions are are we
talking yeah well Shelly Taylor and
Jonathan Brown yeah my my understanding
is that these are the sort of innocuous
types of things that come from making
downward comparison so I'm I'm better
than average that type of s yes
she said she says those are innocuous
right that right that's my understanding
so so when as for example if you ask
people to raate their ability on a
multitude of traits if if everybody in
this room rated themselves we all the
whole group as a whole would be above
average everybody can see above average
and and this is a positive illusion
that's Garrison town in Wisconsin right
where every child is above
average that's true but we can't we
can't by definition all be above aage so
so that's sort of definition of positive
illusions but it's but isn't it sort of
a leap to go from that type of positive
illusion to self-deception that could
have
um the content of which has to do with
your relationships with other people and
truths about the world and and all kinds
of other things I mean
where's well it is the Le because CV and
block has have just finished a study on
people who are high in self-deception
and found that over the course of a
5year period those very people were in
fact rated by their peers as much more
dislikable and in more psychological
trouble than people who are low self
self-deception the same as as the people
who are thinking that they're above
average are these the same
things in other words self-deception
sounds I don't know because IUD sort of
self-deception would be the denial of
information positive illusion would be
that hasn't that hasn't been completely
sorted out what if you told this person
no the truth is you are average yeah and
they accepted
it in other words it seems to they're
looking slightly different things well
like I said in the literature as as a
whole that hasn't been sorted out even
like we're using one of the inventories
of self-deception in our lab right now
to try to sort some of this out and it's
got different it's it's one scale with
different Factor subcategories one of
which is self-enhancement which would be
more like I'm more than average and the
other ones there's two others one of
which has to do with the denial of
negative information and maybe one of
those is more pathological than the
other and maybe one isn't pathological
at all although I would bed on it but I
don't know for sure what is really the
difference because if you say that I if
you if you suggest that if you believe
that you are better than you are then
that means you're not going to believe
that you need to fix one of the things
that we did with this by the way we've
done an experiment with this
questionnaire and we found that people
who are if you give these people
standard tests of psychological Health
well you can't tell because they might
be lying because they lie after all are
you neurotic well no you know but let's
let's say they're not neurotic well what
we did was took we took people and we
looked at the tendency to self-enhance
we divided them into high self-enhancers
and low self-enhancers then we gave them
20 photographs to rate we used the Neo
the five Factor personality model to see
how they would rate other people who
were just we took a sensus cross-section
of race and age and then we and we used
five Neo adjectives per picture and then
collapsed them all together to kind of
get their average their average
personality inferential model which is
imagine you force all those 20 pictures
together you get a composite individual
plus you get a composite personality
score people high and Self
Enhancement regarded others as more
negative because we we put all the
negative adjectives into one category
and all the positives in another as more
negative than they regarded themselves
so I would say no there's no difference
wait but the mechanism for make those
positive Evolutions is making downward
comparisons which is exactly what these
people did right right well
cin and block found that people who do
that are rated by their peers as
less well less socially as worse than
people who don't over the long term that
has short-term advantages but that's
that's neuroticism it has short-term
advantages that's why people do it
people also tend to make down
comparisons when they have their sight
set well this is something Ain is trying
to work this out because she thinks that
some of these these inventories of uh
self-deception are contaminated with
optimism and I think she's right is that
optimistic people who think I can make
the future brighter than probability
says it is likely to be which I think is
a perfectly reasonable stance and is
dependent on your ability to work she
thinks those people get lumped together
with with the self deceivers proper well
sure they would because if they took as
their reference group one level of
accomplishment up I think I can do
better for myself right right well a lot
of this has to be pulled apart
comparisons to their peers right
absolutely I mean and it's not all that
easy to pull out a positive belief in
the future and its possibilities from
I've already got that positive future
now even though all the evidence
suggests that the contrary is true so
that's right a fantasy about how good
things might be is not necessarily
pathological unless you presume that
things are already that way in fact you
need a you need a fantasy like that to
keep you going ahead so I think the
fundamental problem with that positive
illusion lies fact that it impes their
learning which is exactly what we're
talking about so their denying error
well here's another example we ran an
experiment because we're very interested
in this particular line of research
because it contradicts everything I'm
trying to say in this course so course
that personally irritates me as well as
well as you
know well for all sorts of other reasons
I just can't believe that Shelley
Taylor's right in like 5,000 years of
religious Traditions gathered from all
over the world are wrong just strikes me
as highly unlikely anyways we we use
this we use this test that has been used
to discriminate Psychopaths from non
Psychopaths now so thing about
Psychopaths is that while they're not
very pleasant to be around in the long
term although superficially they can be
very Charming in fact they make a study
of how to be Charming in fact if you do
group therapy with Psychopaths which is
a very bad idea they become more
effective Psychopaths because they pick
up a whole psychological vocabulary and
an array of professional techniques that
they would never otherwise have access
to so anyways they're not very anxious
and depressed but they're also dangerous
now there's a test that has been used to
distinguish Psychopaths from non
Psychopaths it's called the Newman card
playing task and Daniel computerized it
up for use in this study um it consists
of an Extinction Paradigm none of you
are going to take this I hope I might
you might
yeah
I should take well no depends you can't
take it if you listen to this you
probably shouldn't take it anyways
because you've been in this course so
you'll kind of know what the hell's
going on possibly so you wouldn't be a
good subject okay so stay out of our
experiment
anyways anyways uh okay so you have
there's 100 cards and they're stacked
the deck is stacked and in the first
deck there's 10 cards and their face
cards every time you turn over the face
card to get a quarter you start with
some money get a quarter and then in the
next deck of 10 the subject doesn't
notice of course one out of 10 of the
cards makes you lose randomly and in the
next deck two out of the 10 make you
lose then three out of 10 four out of 10
five out of 10 and so on all the way
until the end where 10 out of 10 make
you lose now your instructions are do
you ever win again no it's an Extinction
parag so you win the first time and well
you win no you win for the first 50% of
the right because you win 10 times then
you win n then you win eight then you
win seven cards winners or losers that's
the cards are either winners or losers
now all you have to do is decide when to
stop now the object is to maximize your
money obviously well High self-
deceivers make half as much money as low
self deceivers because they don't know
when to quit and I think the reason they
don't know when to quit is
because losing is indication of error
it's labeled with negative out that's
what stops you if you habitually ignore
all signs of error why you're not going
to stop doing something stupid as fast
fast as you should so anyways they make
half as much money as low self-deceivers
so wait I'm sorry I understand so they
keep going longer than they should but
do you you start losing money or just
stop winning no no you oh every time one
of these sorry maybe my explanation was
confusing yeah you either win a quarter
or lose a quarter that's right right so
the ratio of wins to losses decreases
over time linearly and you should stop
somewhere in the 50/50 range right or
maybe a little after that because
whatever but somewhere around there when
you're losing as often as you're winning
and you can see because the the numbers
total up on the screen and the quarters
appear or disappear so you can tell when
you hit the maximum so then that seems
to me complicated with the optimism
variable because if somebody just thinks
well I'm going to just get keep going
you know well it's it's conceivable like
this is this is a hard thing to factor
out it's conceivable that it's
contaminated by optimism I would say
that under the circumstances of the test
optimism is unwarranted past a certain
point so yeah I mean because to be
optimistic you would have to assume that
the deck isn't stacked and therefore it
came back but since the things are
decreasing incrementally one by one I
mean you might figure out pretty quickly
that it was set up well yeah well that's
that's the hope is you figure it out
that's right you stop in lots of things
in life are like that I mean you know
you do something and it it it's working
it's working and then it doesn't work so
well and then works even less well and
you know sooner or later you should quit
now obviously that can be contaminated
up by persistence the other thing we did
was we had these people put their finger
in a pain device minor Le Pain device
you it's just a it's just a a
lever it's kind of about as sharp as a
dull butter knife it sits on your finger
and there's weights on it when you first
put your and you can take it off
whenever you want when you first put
your finger in there doesn't hurt at all
but the pressure sums the pain P
detectors sum the pain and all we say is
well tell us when this hurts so people
are looking at it oh it hurts now we
also say take your finger out when a
reasonable person would do so so you
know they usually stay there for about
30 seconds or so and then they say well
you know that's enough it's completely
harmless but the high self- deceivers
stay in there longer than the low self-
deceivers too now you might say Well
they're persistent well they are they
are persistent and sometimes that's good
and it's hard to tell when it's not good
but sometimes it's not good and I would
say leaving your finger in a laboratory
pain device longer than average is
probably not
good there might be some distinction
here between sort of a metacognitive
assessment of the likelihood which is
some something that's not like an
immediate behavioral thing like like if
you're optimistic and you have these
far-reaching goals that would seem to be
healthy but if if you apply those in
small like minute immediate behavioral
level things like this should have been
behavioral learning like you're not
supposed to figure out cognitively okay
it's incrementally
but to behavioral information they will
never I mean by definition then their
optimistic sense is flawed Because
unless you have the ability to adapt to
the everyday behavioral information you
can't learn and get progress right right
that's yes that's that's a a good
explanation for for the phenomenon in
the experiment p and it's not a
definitive experiment by any means but
but it's interesting because it even
argues against the shortterm utility of
of failure to process information that
indicates that you're in error and it is
to self-deception since we use the
self-deception questionnaire so so
you're equating the Psychopathology of
neuroticism with
psychopathy yes I guess so that's what
I'm
doing you know I guess what I should say
though having said that is
that there are certain this doesn't mean
that I don't believe that there are
genetic predispositions to different
forms of
Psychopathology and it also I it also
doesn't mean that I believe that
everyone plays on the same field so to
speak so it may be that if you say you
have an extensive family history of
schizophrenia well that means that it's
going to take a lot
less to push you over the edge than it
would a normal person and the fact that
you've gone over the edge so to speak is
not any indication necessarily that your
moral character was any less than the
next person so the parameters of the
game shift with genetic and
environmental contexts which is to say
that I guess in part that different
people have different Temptations and
also different weaknesses
and but but I I do think that there's a
moral aspect to mental
illness
so that's it's
Troublesome okay before we leave the uh
tor shy Taylor article real quick I
think it's important to point out that
what she actually says and it's been
pointed out by col block another
critique is not that positive Illusions
are correlated with mental health but
positive Illusions are correlated with
the absence of depression and anxiety
yeah which is a very different thing
yeah well she takes the argument farther
than that though because look she wrote
a self-help book for people telling them
how to use positive self- Illusions to
enhance the mental function so there
she's
extrapolating Beyond the mere statement
of absence of depression and anxiety
which is not a statement I have a
problem with because Psychopaths for
example are low in depression and
anxiety it's taking the argument the
next step that's the problem right
so so I do think she goes beyond just
while these these restricted forms of
Psychopathology are less frequent among
people who are high in self-deception
that in itself is just an interesting
phenomenon it's the next step that sort
of disturbs me so
is that sat sa satisfying yeah that's
what I was saying oh oh okay okay okay
sorry I guess I kind of misunderstood
what you were
say is it pical then to have hope in the
face to like almost like hope against
hope well this is this argument gets
more complicated there like one of the
things that she's found is that people
who say If you're diagnosed with
intractable cancer well she's found that
people who overestimate their chance of
survival
live longer now this is this is tough I
mean you know that's the the piece of
her evidence that's really compelling
but I would suggest and you know
hopefully I can do more than suggest at
some point that that's because she has
optimism her notion of
self-deception um improperly
incorporates this sort of optimism that
we've been
discussing because in that card Paradigm
couldn't it just be like I'm probably be
one of the psychopath play till the end
because I keep hoping that the next card
would be like the one that gives me a
quarter I hope I'm not pathological like
yeah but you don't know how you'd behave
in the task either so I you know I
wouldn't draw don't draw any inferences
about your behavior hypothetically
because you don't know you might have
stop right I mean I don't know either
maybe you would play right to the end
but it's also Pro possible that some of
the people just didn't care about the
damn quarters but they like the game I
mean they spend quarters to play the
games at the arcade possibly it's kind
of a dull game though I mean we tell
people you're supposed to win the money
it's like proper behavior during this
test is winning the money so the goal is
set so I mean you know like I said it's
not it's
not it's not a definitive case so did
you did you have another call oh yeah I
just wanted to ask
um talking about Hope and and um anxiety
and everything the words Pride fear
hatred and revenge what's the neuros
pychological ve of like like fear is you
know activation of the
right but what about pride and revenge
well this I don't know about this you
know but the the negative emotions they
tend to Clump right if you look at the
neuroticism scale of the ne all negative
emotional states are in the same
subscale essentially anger for example
correlates very highly with fear so and
anger but we know that anger is um
activation of the left cortex not the
right
cortex and I was wondering if Revenge
might be the same way I mean it seems
like there's an approach there's an
approach aspect rather than than an
avoidance aspect to Revenge as well as
yeah no that's a good point I don't I
don't know like we haven't we haven't
progressed very far in the study of
these sorts of higher order emotions I
don't know what the neuros pychological
correlates would be I mean as anger is
not necessarily proactive but active
aggression certainly seems to involve
approach Behavior so you know you
could but I mean there may a lot of it
maybe in response to fear I mean it's
they become the farther you go in terms
of outward Behavior the more complex
it's going to have to be from the
original impression okay no I don't
follow that well this is It's just to
say that fear is one of the fundamental
responses that happens that happens
instantly I mean in the right fral
cortex but then as soon as you're
getting into hatred and revenge you're
getting into planed sequences of
behaviors that are naturally going to be
activating systems in and different
systems too you're no that's a really
that's an astute comment because when
you say aggression for example what
you're saying is a word that contains
you know 40 different categories of
Behavioral output because there's
defensive aggression there's uh
instrumental aggression there's
anger just you know just for starters
there's there's aggression that's
socially appropriate there's aggression
that's socially inappropriate there's
aggression that's punishment elicited
aggression that's fear elicited uh
aggression as a response to challenge to
group identity and all those different
things are under the rubric of one word
but as you point out involve activation
of systems that that may be in complete
opposition to one another at times the
Hope thing seems to me to be something
that like if like it seems there's two
totally different things that in
everyday life we call Hope and one would
be of equivalent to the hero and the
other one would be equivalent to like an
over rigid identification with a social
structure because like if you say um you
have hope in the future that that hope
can be the kind of thing that keeps you
looking for other Alternatives and helps
you find your way around messes and sort
of motivates you forward um into anomaly
or into whatever like the hear the
encounter the new information or you can
have the kind of thing that we don't
distinguish we call it hope too but it's
the kind of thing where you you say it
keeps you from finding a way around
things because you say this one will
work out talking about is more like
Faith okay because hope I think you can
actually categorically Define hope in a
sense and I would say hope is what you
experience as a consequence of the
positive veilance of an anomalous
occurrence which is to say that you
experience the affect of Hope when
you're faced with an a cue for
satisfaction with an incentive reward
and that accompanies activation of the
left front of Cortex this I think what
you're talking about is this and you're
I think you're making a distinction
between Blind Faith which is oh
everything's going to turn out
wonderfully you know even when The
Barbarians are at the gate so to speak
and the faith that says no matter what
comes up which means I know that things
will transform I can deal with the
Transformations if my attitude is proper
and it's certainly the case that those
two things can be one is adolescent
Faith that's what I'd say it's all my it
isn't even faith in a sense it's
Reliance on the group like if I fall
over the group will maintain me or
protect me from those things I can't
control the other one is you know I know
the world's a dynamic place there's
something in me that can respond to it
that's like an absolute I think that's
the antithesis of the of the position
that motivates the lie it's also the
case see one of the questions we're
trying to answer is we know the group
has a protective
nature that's also
necessary but that can be pathologized
so the question is given that the group
is necessary that its maintenance is
necessary that people have to identify
with it how is it that the pathological
aspect can be reduced and I would say to
the degree that you're able to move your
faith from blind Reliance on the group
to your own capacity to address
anomalous information and transform it
into explored territory
you're you to the degree that you're
able to do that you can simultaneously
cut your dependent Ties on the group
because you have this alternative
standpoint that's right there's two ways
of there's two modes of protection from
the great unknowing one is well Dad will
do everything that's one way of looking
at the other is well no nothing can do
everything but if I'm willing to meet
whatever happens when it happens I can
heighten the probability of success to
to its highest possible level and that
works out because first of all you're
always practicing and that's that's
psychological hygiene as far as I'm
concerned you know I think that's why so
many religious Traditions concentrate on
heightening attention to day-to-day
processes so little bits of anomalous
information are always cropping up in
your interpersonal interactions and in
your professional work and everything
that you do and if you if you learn how
to respond to those anomalous
occurrences that are relatively small
while they're happening first of all you
keep your personality healthy you
practice knowing how to do it so you
increase your confidence in yourself you
decrease the amount of territory around
you that's contaminated by the unknown
and you increase the likelihood that
when something really catastrophic comes
along that you'll make the right
decision it's important you know because
you see in places like Nazi Germany for
example and certainly not uniquely that
all sorts of people who we might have
hoped would have been more resistant to
the Nazi ideology fell over like sheep
when it was pared out the intellectual
Community seem to have no better record
than the community at Large in Germany
so which which to me indicates that
despite their accumulation of fact there
was no concentration whatsoever on the
development of character that weakens
necessarily weakens the resistance of
the
state um so I'm trying to think about
what how you can distinguish between The
Optimist and the psychopath in your
experiments and what it seems to be to
me uh in my exper in my experience
that um or or maybe at least from from
your experiments that the psychopath
goes on uh ignoring threat but even
while being punished um now I'm trying
to figure out if it's being punished by
the known or by unknown unkknown things
because when he sticks the finger in the
thing that's something that's known that
it's going to hurt you you know they and
they stick it in longer so that's what
I'm trying to figure out The
Optimist I think ignores threat but does
not uh keep going on being punished um
by by the known or the unknown yeah I
doubt I doubt I doubt if it breaks down
I doubt if it breaks down that
straightforwardly I mean um The Optimist
is someone I think who's willing to
endure and voluntarily meet threatening
conditions in order to attain their end
but who also modifies their behavior as
a consequence of encounter that's that's
the critical thing is that The Optimist
is who's healthy is has a an ideal that
may even be impossible in fact fact I
think in some ways if you don't have an
impossible ideal then your ideal is
wrong it should always supersede your
grasp I
mean that's the whole point of an ideal
it's something that as you approach it
it receives but transforms you along the
way so you might say well that's a
pathological fantasy since it can never
be brought into existence but there's a
difference
between your conception of the future as
an ideal place and your and your belief
that despite all evidence the present is
that ideal place at least in so far as
it's composed of you apart from all
these other you know horrible people
that happen to surround you so like the
distinction between persistence and
stubbornness or hardheadedness or
whatever I'm trying to understand the
distinction between uh hope the kind of
Hope necessary for uh to risk action and
optimism yeah well again I would say
that's I would say that's Faith actually
Corell West talks about it of Hope Oh
yes okay uh required to sustain
political activism in the face of
right in the face ofid the face of of
evidence that all your personal efforts
are useless yeah right right so that's
healthy
depends again it's very it's very
dangerous to try to identify a
definition of that something that can be
defined as
healthy okay so let me see if I can
address that more
particularly it's
adaptive I mean our society is
predicated on the idea that despite all
appearances there's something Divine
about the
individual right I think what Cornell
West is referring to is the necessity of
acting on that belief even though it
even though number one it's
incomprehensible and number two it seems
to exist despite the evidence now you
say well what would separate that from a
delusion well I think there is evidence
to support the notion that it's accurate
because for one thing those societies
that make that presupposition seem to
work much better than those who don't
and that strikes me as a form of
evidence plus I mean what we consider
evidence that's very difficult to to
come to any agreement about but it also
strikes me that if you look at
traditional wisdom in these myths for
example what's constantly pointed out is
look you don't understand the function
of the individual there's more to it
that meets the eye the more to it being
the individual is the the phenomena that
creates order out of chaos so the
Incarnation of Marduk so to speak plus
the force that rejuvenates the archaic
social system when it needs to be
rejuvenated and I mean that those two
things account for the Divinity of the
individual so to speak and I would say
well even though it may not be evident
to you necessarily in your actions how
that is playing out if you're doing it
for the right reasons
then it will play itself out n said you
know all revolutions start invisibly
which is his explicit recapitulation of
a hero myth because the hero is always
born under you know trivial and
threatened conditions so Moses for
example is he's going to be he's
threatened with death by the Pharaoh and
let go on a river and in in the
Christian story Christ is born in the
stable and Herod threatens him with
death and that's just a sign that you
know terribly important things may have
the may have the outside appearance even
of failure but that's no indication
necessarily that they're failure well
then you say well how the hell do you
separate that from delusion well that
ties into that's a good way of closing
this that ties into this look you can't
tell using objective evidence if you're
if what you're doing is going to be
successful partly because you have the
wrong time frame so maybe the thing
you're doing is absolutely right no one
will know it for 300 years you're not
going to know it because you're not
going to be here so how do you know well
the only thing I can the only way I can
think of that you might know is by
watching how your
actions by watching how your belief and
actions let me say it again what is it
that you
want let me just get this
right the thing that tends to turn
people against life is the fact that
life is full of inexplicable tragedies I
would say that if you can develop a
motive of an ude towards the world
that's characterized by an increase in
the ability to Bear its tragic
circumstances that that's evidence that
your attitude is correct now the only
person who's going to be able to
determine that is you because it's not
going to be evident necessarily to
people around you and it may not play
out the way you would want it to in the
external world so then the question is
how is it that you can come to the state
where you can trust your own judgment
about your beliefs given that people's
beliefs get out of hand all the time and
they say well this belief is right well
that that that ties back into this if
you fill up your head with information
that you know to by your own definitions
of Truth to be false then you can ensure
that you're not going to be able to
trust your own judgment now the problem
is there's going to be times in your
life where your judgment is the only
judgment that can even possibly be valid
and it it better be the case that when
you're in that circumstance that your
head is free enough of Lies so that you
can be certain that the decision you're
making is right so I would say and then
this is the thing that's going to
underly the last lecture in the course
is there's two poles of there's there's
two poles that underly your ability to
determine if you're on the right path
this way one is you're doing something
that you're interested in that's
meaningful enough so that you say even
with all the tragedy of Life the fact
that I can do this makes it all
worthwhile and the second thing is you
better make sure that you're not diluted
in what's making you interested and the
only way you can be sure of that is that
you're not lying because you might end
up developing an interest in in ax
murdering because that happens to people
or in slaughtering and then their
interest guides them somewhere it
shouldn't have gone and I would say well
that's because they pathologized
themselves by filling their brain so to
speak filling their mind with
information they know to they know is
not vertical so there's two polls one is
wear something meaningful manifest
itself follow it now people want to do
that anyways that's what makes your life
interesting the other thing is whenever
you have the opportunity make sure sure
that you tell yourself the truth because
if you don't your interest is going to
become sicken and then it'll lead you
somewhere you do not want to
go
anyways so our last class is next week
and
we'll fold everything
up I have your your essays by yes yes
would you say that most of the if a
person continually repeats Behavior but
they knowas that they like the behavior
so much um in the days they don't like
like that that it continually create
like that like let's say would you say
that that's probably a rationalization
most of